I think if Trump gets reelected it's
going to flare up again what will flare
up the wokeness I don't think so and
here's why there's wokeness in the
activist class and there's wokeness in
the elite right and the elite only care
about wokeness in so far is it maintains
and controls their power back in
20156 you could not stop from hearing in
the states about refugees welcome we
need more Muslim immigration Linda sarur
was this Greta thunberg figure that they
just brought her out every 5 minutes and
she's the spokesperson for this whole
movement that's completely vanished and
completely gone away you literally never
hear them talk about this this was a
total Victory by the right but since so
many people on the right here regard
themselves as Perpetual victims and just
only want to complain about whatever the
leftists are talking about right now and
they live in a Perpetual present they've
completely forgotten that this was a
battle that they've totally
won